and these companies are now worth each
over 30 billion dollars
where what they're doing is
fundamentally providing a solution you
just
put in your own system hey developers
you need a payment solution for your app
stripe makes it easy you can handle sms
messaging
video chat twilio has apis for that
jeremy glasenberg thank you for joining
me on 20 minute leaders how are you
i am doing well how are you doing i i'm
great are you ready to talk about apis
developers developer relations
always in i am extremely excited
i've been talking to quite a few you
know technology enthusiasts
entrepreneurs investors about all sorts
of different customers in different
markets
i'm excited to dive deep now into the
developer market and what it means to
build
products that developers love what do
apis mean
not just on a technical level but also
you know historically how have they
shaped our use of technology and
creating a more integrated world but
before all that jeremy tell me a little
bit about yourself and
and throw in there a little bit about
you know being the mascot for
firefox i think that would be
fascinating oh right that little
side side item all right well yeah high
level been uh doing the product
management thing for a little over 12
years now
um with a specialty and uh it's kind of
irrational obsession
with uh with apis and developer
experiences
uh what i'm most well known for is is
box i was
basically the first hire for their
developer platform as a pm
and basically over time built out
everything necessary there to
get a developer ecosystem going i've
also built out a developer platform over
at a trade shift that's the other
unicorn company i'm allowed to talk
about
as a consultant i've helped so several
other now unicorn companies
uh either build and launch or redesign
re-implement and relaunch their their
apis
we're working really in a range of
industries enterprise software education
software drones even the private space
industry
it's a nice thing about working on apis
you really just can
can help out many many spaces so
the firefox mascot how did you even get
involved with firefox mozilla
and and what what did you end up with
the mascot yeah um
and if you want the full story i
actually interviewed at mozilla while in
grad school
uh got got rejected um
i kind of i accepted the the decision
because at the time i had very little
work experience and that that was the
concern but i just
really liked the people i met i got i
learned a lot about their
open source community and i want to get
involved afterwards
and uh and so i did that actually was a
great story of overall just
how you know just you know karma can
really help out with your career because
at one point they were interested
in hiring me again and at the time i
wasn't about to leave the startup i was
at
so they understood i was genuinely just
helping them out because i want to help
them out
but the recruiters who remember that
actually went on to become talent
partners at vc firms
so my time at mozilla unintentionally
helped me out
over over the course of my career but
the firefox mascot
at one point i was invited to i think it
was firefox's fifth birthday party
and uh whoever was supposed to be in the
costume
basically got overheated so someone
asked if i was uh
willing to help out and uh you know sent
me the photo long story short and
firefox is one wild guy
i i love that i completely love that
jeremy
you mentioned that you have this weird
obsession and passion for api
so before we talk about you know the
history of apis and how critical they
are to our
to our you know developer economy today
tell me a little bit about what apis are
you know even for the people that may be
non-technical listening to this
yeah and i have to emphasize that my my
focus has been mostly
on web apis but apis
application programming interfaces
they're basically a way of letting
different programs talk to each other
in the web what that can mean for the
semi-technical folk is you when you go
to a browser
and you're going to google.com you're
going to get back some html javascript
some stuff that tells chrome this is
what to show to the user
in an api we're just returning we used
to return xml
now we're returning json but it's a
format that basically tells
another program what's going on
so it's just a way of letting apps
interact with each other
more than the users having their direct
interactions that allow some
more automated operations to happen in
the background
and as we've seen in the use cases a lot
of companies basically
enabling more for their customers than
they ever could
by by partnering with other experts by
partnering with other services
right so tell me a little bit about what
opportunities this opens up because
because you know if we're looking at the
world until let's say 1970 1980 even
before the internet
every company technology company needed
to build its own on-premise technology
that serves itself right
what has this communication and
integration
what opportunities has this opened up
for the world well you know we've seen
before the days of the internet
the benefits of opening up your
operating system that was you know the
big thing for for microsoft windows
and they said we're gonna let anyone
write apps on top of our software
we're gonna be cross-platform we're
gonna be open to others to to build and
write apps
and uh what happens there is then you
enable much more functionality for
for your users there are many other use
cases for apis though
but if we get into your web apis uh when
i joined box
back in in we actually had several value
propositions
for the the apis uh box is on its
simplicity it's way to upload files
download files do other stuff good too
it's basically it's an online
content management collaboration
solution
boxes marketing team is going to hate me
for saying this but many will say we're
the enterprise version of dropbox
but basically we had actually three key
value points for our apis
one was having our apis as a feature
solution
for channel partners so it could be a
mobile app that needed to get content on
and off
of their application or utilize sharing
functionality
and so through our apis they could
enable that if they just let their users
connect with box
so we were a feature benefit and then
those sort of partners could bring us
new users item two was then
we had customers coming in asking do you
have
this capability and maybe we didn't
maybe we weren't even going to build it
because it was either one off or was
going to be too difficult
but hey can somebody else do it and we
would find someone else who could
provide a solution help us close these
300 400 000 plus deals
and then number three was where our
customers had their own infrastructure
their own internal network and they want
to connect their existing internal
software with what we had a box to
further automate the experience
so very often it's uh it's for internal
tools there are
many many value points for a developer
platform many ways to
to monetize john muster who's the
founder of programmable web he
regularly gave a talk at this conference
glucon
we would highlight all of the new ways
of monetization and his
just diagram keep getting bigger and
bigger every year
um but among others we could talk about
you know a box
box was a customer facing product with a
complimentary platform
what we're seeing now are stripes and
twilios and these companies where the
core
product is an api and these companies
are now worth each over 30
billion dollars or what they're doing is
fundamentally providing a solution you
just put in your own system
hey developers you need a payment
solution for your app
stripe makes it easy you can handle sms
messaging
video chat twilio has apis for that
right so what i'm hearing for you jeremy
is that one of the biggest shifts that
we've seen
especially in the last 10 years is
companies understanding there are these
software
needs that a lot of different
organizations have these
needs are quite complicated convoluted
and and they cost quite a lot of money
to maintain and make sure that they're
really scalable and
and secure as well so if we can provide
those solutions
in the form of an of a web api then
others around the world can then just
license it from us and enjoy them
where are we headed with this
integration are we just opening
ourselves up to
you know an explosion of a marketplace
where do you see
the world of apis moving you know when
it comes to marketplaces i happen to
actually teach
a course on that and this isn't to
advertise let's give a disclaimer that
course is two and a half hours long
so uh that's a whole other other topic
but marketplace has certainly come up in
the world of apis at marketplaces
salesforce's app exchange
and that's one business model where apis
come up
um in general i like to just at the
highest level categorize the businesses
by
those companies that have a core
customer consumer facing product
with a complementary platform and the
stripes in the twilios of the world
where the platform is the product
and also api tooling now
for any of these marketplaces
come up api tooling by the way is more
when you're actually building an api
there are these tools to help you build
the api and that's been trending very
well over the past
few years but among the trends we've
seen were
in category a many companies whose
business model are
very much dependent on having those apis
at some companies it's 30 percent of the
revenue and other companies it's 99
of the revenue requires the the api as
an enterprise tech
it may not be fundamentally enabling a
company but they need it for every deal
they're closing
um and if and when it comes to the api's
only companies
you know we've seen multiple decacorns
30 billion
plus companies forming the last few
years and so
you know we only anticipate more of that
many vcs have spoken with me about that
and
yes i anticipate more of that right and
all the while there have been these um
you know hipsters in api world who were
trying to whip up these solutions to
make it easier
and that's the trend i like to talk
about of the general trends and
expectations and product quality what it
takes to actually build apis today
um but the api tooling space has really
taken off in the last couple years
we're just starting to see some unicorns
it's not as big
as the you know api's core companies
but the tooling space is is doing well
as the demand for apis rise as the
expectations the standards now um
for developers they're expecting better
standards for their apis
and then they need to be able to build a
good api as well that's coming up more
and more so we are seeing more demand in
the api tooling space
so tell me a little bit you know give me
a broad understanding of what is this
tooling space that that you're talking
about what does it mean to to an api
tool for those api centered companies
so at its core there's usually the api
gateway it's basically when you're
building and ready to launch an
api there's this tool to help you manage
the api
it sits the front it takes in those api
requests
and it can filter for you it can handle
ddos attacks
it can handle rate limiting or maybe an
app that didn't have any malicious
intent
is just doing something wrong they're
making too many calls and maybe can
catch some errors for you
but beyond that there are these other
tools to help you with the design of the
apis
and the developer community aspect
itself
it goes to what i call the api product
lifecycle
and uh let me know if i'm going off
topic here but something always
emphasizes when it comes to no no this
is fantastic
and this applies for tooling for api
only companies
for anything when you're working on an
api i've seen a lot of success
i've also seen many spectacular failures
and the number one reason for failures
are when these companies
get the idea of if you build it they
will come
which we know doesn't work anywhere else
in product management for but for
whatever reason that's still lingering
in the world of apis uh and
and by the way as a chicago one i have
to note if so the movie where this
actually comes from
a field of dreams uh what actually
happens is they build this
uh a baseball field that attracts the
ghosts
of the chicago white sox players who
took a bribe to throw a world series
when you think about it even in the
movie where this comes from they didn't
really attract the kind of customers you
want
but sometimes they think it's by
developers for developers so
the business spoken so let's just throw
this problem at the engineers and the
engineers are saying like
what do we do i mean we have some
internal apis let's slap some
documentation on that we don't really
know what we're doing here
and they start and that's where you come
in right that's where we come in and so
what i encourage
is the api product life cycle and
something very interesting is happening
is uh there's this trend of encouraging
api standards
making it easier to design certain
consistent quality apis
and some of the tools originally were
helpful for developers who are whipping
up internal apis
but now it's about supporting the api
product cycle which i should
clarify it's basically treat this like a
product problem
it's just that your customers happen to
be developers
so and what does that mean jeremy
because i think that's an important
distinction because
there's very different in i think that
first of all obviously developers we are
a
special kind of species and we have
different expectations and we absorb and
we
give feedback in a different way what
does that mean to have
to have developers as your primary
customer so
let's take box as an example this is a
company
where we had a core customer facing
product and then
the apis were for partners various types
of partners
okay well who are the partners we're
going to be working with
what are the sort of apps they're going
to build how do we make it as
easy as possible for them to build those
apps
sometimes it's in the design of your
apis sometimes it's the
it's in the additional tooling of the
apis
around the apis uh for instance over a
box we found that there are many
um web services who just want to let
their users move a file in their web
service over the box
rather than having to download it to
their desktop and then uploading it to
box
now in order to do this with a basic api
that says you can upload files
you can get a user's you know folder
structure and display that to the user
you can handle authentication
it would still take a decent number of
api calls to do this
but we saw enough companies doing the
same thing so we figured can we just
make it easier for them
do we give them a script in their case
we actually had at one point just a url
box.com import uh you put that
link in front of the download link and
it would just send the user over to box
we would authenticate the user
and let them you know pick a folder and
upload for them so we just made their
lives easier
as another example i once worked in in
the supply chain in invoicing
and this was a company that in principle
was apis first eat your own dog food
also restful i shouldn't shoot too much
detail around that but rest is basically
a
common standard for way to design
structured scalable apis well
and they had all of that and they had
this elegant api that didn't fit for
their use cases
in say the world of invoicing it should
take
you one have one api call say create an
invoice it took five api calls
um because you can apply these standards
of rest and everything else
but if you're not thinking through what
are the sort of apps that are gonna be
built what are they trying to do
and then make it easier you're not going
to have a good developer experience
so it starts with understanding your
developers knowing the kind of things
they're going to do and then designing
your apis
according to use case then implementing
the apis
and that's really where the product side
of things comes about right that's where
you're
you're saying that it's not just you
know take whatever existing apis we have
let's slap
slap on some you know documentation on
them and just release them it's really
understand
putting that putting it as a product
facing a agenda
understanding what at the end of the
primary use cases and
is our do our api satisfy those
product requirements that our users
actually want they obviously don't want
to call those
five apis to get to their end result
they want to call this one restful api
right
yeah and you have known the twilio folk
from their early early days
and i knew they were going to take off
because they understood this they had
you just says any good product
management customer empathy they had
developer empathy
and they designed api as well and they
designed
a good developer experience stripe was
famous for this as well
they actually did it without product
managers it was by engineers for
engineers
so twilio i was a company i've known
since the early days and i could tell
they were going to take off because
they have what we call developer empathy
which is just like customer empathy for
any other area of product
and stripe as well you could see it they
designed their apis based on use case
they designed their developer website
accordingly
stripe was famous for this really
elegant style of documentation
they did it without product managers it
was by engineers for engineers at stripe
but it wasn't by engineers for
themselves it was engineers
who understood what their developer
community needed
they listened to that community and they
built it accordingly
right that makes a lot of sense jimmy
before we first i have to thank you for
being so generous with your time and how
busy you are
i also have to ask why are you so
passionate about this you know there's
all sorts of different things you can do
with your skill sets
and and with technology in general what
makes you so excited and passionate
about
building great tools for developers and
creating this integrated
workspace yeah you know i've been in api
since before the 2009 api craze when
when apis got cool
but i'm i'm not a hipster definitely not
a hipster
but basically if you want the story it
goes back to i guess late 2005.
do you remember igoogle
wow remember this thing it was an
alternative home page for google
where this customizable page where you
can install these third-party tools and
everything was i-framed-in
wow and i saw that and i was thinking
can i make the web
work like an operating system when i had
to say
the idea was basically igoogle on
caffeine it's called a web top
afterwards a few companies tried it we
had a web page that looked like a
desktop operating system
you could like install web apps and run
them all but
enough sense to figure out that that
idea wasn't actually valuable
um the web as an os was not going to be
like a desktop but one way or another
the web could be an os if services could
talk to each other more
if it was less about the website and
more about the apis to allow these
services to to talk to each other
so i was just in in grad school which
was an mba program hacking away whatever
apis i could find i was actually at one
point top 15 i googled gadget developer
and uh eventually i found the first time
ever a product role was focused just on
apis that a company hadn't heard of at
the time
i actually found the job listing on
craigslist
which was which was box and aaron levy
there was excited about apis before they
were popular too
and we demonstrated value in the company
and apis just you know
took off as a bunch of other companies
demonstrate the value as well
i love that jeremy thank you so so much
for this hey before we leave
the most important question three words
that you would use to describe yourself
uh i should take more more time to think
about that
but um i could just say um whatever
comes to mind with this is not a hard
commitment
i don't want to say irrationally
developer obsessed i think i need to
have
obsessed in some way a developer
experience obsessed how about that
i love that and i think it fits
perfectly to what we've been discussing
these past 20 minutes jeremy thank you
very very much
and stay safe and stay healthy and
continue promoting apis and developer
tools for the rest of the world because
that's where we're headed
and i just love the collaboration i love
that everything is at our fingertips and
almost anything that i need to build i
can pretty much
call on an api and and somebody much
smarter and more
talented did that for me so i think
that's just it's remarkable to me so
thank you for
taking the time to do this with me happy
to chat
happy help thank you take care everyone
foreign